LET THE CULLING GAMES BEGIN, WE’VE ACTUALLY MADE
IT TO THE START OF THE MOST INSANE SAGA SO FAR,
ALWAYS GOTTA SAY SO FAR CAUSE WHO KNOWS WHEN THE
GOAT, FATHER GEGE WILL DROP HIS NEXT MASTERPIECE.
THIS SAGA HERE MAKES SHIBUYA FEEL LIKE THE
PRELUDE ITS MADE OUT TO BE BY THE MASTERMIND
HIMSELF KENJAKU, EVERYTHING TO DO WITH THE CULLING
GAMES HAS TAKEN WHAT WE KNOW WITH JUJUTSU KAISEN
AND ABSOLUTELY FLIPPED IT ON ITS HEAD! BUT
firstly just before I dive into Gege’s nut
intertwined sensation of a story, im going to
be doing something slightly different with this
arc here. Pretty much and like i've said due
to the fact that this is more or less going to
evolve into a saga, im going to break down each
respective colony as its own arc starting with
the first Tokyo Colony. So just before we get
into that, if you are new around here and want
to watch more stuff just like this then make sure
you hit that subscribe button and also be sure to
leave a like as it really helps with pushing
my stuff to a bunch of new amazing people..
So as we start back out we find ourselves in
the middle of a Japanese criminal trial. Its
explained that in Japan, ninety-nine percent
of criminal trials end in a guilty verdict.
A young man sitting opposite the newest G
Higuruma who was introduced right at the
end of the last video, explains that he had
a cat who was lost and while looking for it,
he was confronted by the popo’s. Being struck
with a difficult choice, the young man decided
to flee because his cat would've died, as where
he lives It's a rule that he can't own any pets.
We find that in March of 2016, a mother and
daughter were both slain in Morioka City. This
caused the prosecutors of the case to instantly
suspected the young man. They arrested him and
charged him with suspicion of murder and robbery.
After Keita fled the initial questioning by police
officers, they followed him to his home and found
a bloody blade. (WHICH IS LIKE BRO WHY YOU GOT
THE KNIFE THIS AINT LOOKING GOOD) Once the lab
analysis was complete it confirmed that the blood
on the knife matched the DNA of the two victims.
Despite the outstanding evidence and practically
being caught red-handed by the cops Keita who’s
the young man, insisted that he was innocent.
Why reviewing the case with his co-worker
Shimizu, Higuruma explains that Keita told
him that he picked up the knife even though it
wasn't his. Obviously Shimizu doesn't believe
that that could've possibly happened and instead
thinks he fled from the authorities because he
was simply guilty. Yet for some reason Higuruma
argues that he only fled because in the past he’d
been illegally harassed by police officers
causing him to always be weary of them.
He’d claimed he was going to give the
knife to the police later because his
hostel was sketchy as hell and didn't allow
him to call the police. The reason for this
is because his job around the hostel was to
care for the elderly who have nowhere to go,
employees in the hostel are given a place to stay
and some food but are only paid money under the
table on the new year, while at the same time
still being overcharged each month for rent..
Obviously as you could imagine this effects how
all of the residents would live, more than a few
of the residents who live there have a criminal
records and ever since the 2011 earthquake,
relief fund money started pouring into the region
causing more shady nonprofit businesses to begin
appearing. Higuruma believes it's likely that
the weapon was actually lying around and Keita
is indeed telling the truth… (So well obviously
BIG Higuruma is a freaking G, man is working on
a higher cognitive frequency and is probably
the only damn lawyer in Japan that is adamant
in taking on the courts themselves. PLUS freaking
GEGE again adding in that 2011 tsunami/earthquake
reference is amazing. I just love how it makes
us feel as tho this could actually be going down
now. Or a retelling of an event that effected the
world over the past few years. Anyways anyways)
Higuruma forms a plan to take on the case,
he’ll continue gathering information while
his overworked assistant takes
care of pretty much all else.
The SEXI BIG BRAIN duo go ham working
tirelessly until the day of the trial,
then on the day they manage to somehow earn an
innocent verdict for Keita.. Shimizu is surprised
they actually got the verdict but Higuruma
knows the prosecution will immediately appeal…
In a post-trial meeting, Higuruma reveals to
Keita that nothing from the robbery that was
stolen was ever found in his room and
someone disappeared from the residence
soon after the crime. Above everything else,
Keita also appeared on a convenience store
camera at literally the same time as the
time of death. Hearing this, he thanks
Higuruma but the lawyer simply emphasizes
there will be a second trial... Sobbing,
Keita specifies that he means he just wants
to thank Higuruma for believing in him.
However as per the at the retrial the broken
Japanese judicial system unfortunately found Keita
guilty and the young man was sentenced to life
in prison. Its explained that Independent defense
lawyers like Higuruma rely on limited funding and
no workforce. Public prosecutors have access to
tax money and much greater manpower, because of
this, no new evidence was even presented at the
second trial and the court passed out his sentence
on the shaky argument that there was no reason to
suspect the random person who just happened to go
missing straight after. (Which is like nah dude,
that guy gapped it straight after commiting murder
and your now locking up a completely innocent
person.) Again because of this, a third trial
before the highest court is unlikely as they
refuse to hear most cases. Getting a fair
hearing is improbable and the system itself
unfairly branded Keita as guilty from the very
beginning. AND sadly this is just the reality
of the situation in most countries from the US
to New Zealand, as soon as you are being sat
infront of a dury you already have somewhat of
bad connotation put over your head! Moral of the
story is just don't get yourself in the situation
where your being charged with something in court.)
Desperate and angry, Keita looks at Higuruma
with sorrow and disappointment in his eyes.
Standing there Shocked, Higuruma just
asks himself why his clients always look
at him in this way. Losing touch with reality
for a moment, he thinks back to a conversation
he had about his mental state. There he replied
that it wasn't his intention to save the weak,
he's always been the type of person
who couldn't ignore things. Justice
is supposed to be blind and people close their
eyes to spare themselves from the harsh truths
of reality, but even if hes the only one,
Higuruma says he wants to keep his eyes.
Back in court now, The judge announces that
if there are any objections, then they must
be filed within fifteen days. Not FREAKING
HAPPY THOUGH and wanting to make a damn change,
Higuruma abruptly interrupts and slams his table
with a mallet that turns out to be a judge's gavel
of his own. This leaves absolutely everyone in
the court room surprised and as Shizumi begins
to move away, a large dark curse begins to form
behind Higuruma. Refusing to allow the trial to
end in this unjust manner, Higuruma snaps and
tells everyone that nobody is allowed to leave
because they're now having a retrial. So yeeesss,
this absolutely dope ass new character is indeed a
Culling Game player and this event has served as
a catalyst for his powers to awaken... (Which is
just to dope, I love the idea that Higuruma
manifests his technique through wanting to
bring forth his own kind of Justice. It really
reminds me of the admirals in One Piece and how
each of them differ in terms of their of forms
of justice and what they think It should be!
Okay as per usual with FATHER Gege we skip
over elsewhere just before 6am back on the
1st of November and find ourselves with
Kenjaku who is LEGIT CREEEPING ON Sasaki,
BTW JUST GONNA BLOW YOUR
MIND IF YOU HAVENT REALIZED,
THIS IS THE FREAKING GIRL FROM THE VERY FIRST
EPISODE, YUJI’s OLD FRIEND THAT HE SAVED! SOOO
WHAT THE ACTUAL HELL DOES HE HAVE IN STORE
HERE!. ANYWAYS! Petrified as you would be
with waking up and finding a man above you
in bed, Setsuko asks who this weirdo is.
Its explained to her, that he's the sorcerer who
placed a barrier over Sendai and that the region
has been chosen to host a lethal contest where
players will fight to the death. The remains of
an execution site nearby serves as the center
of the barrier with a radius of around five
to six kilometers. (Which is interesting,
I wonder if had to set up a bunch of these
execution sites throughout each barrier in his
thousand or so years proceeding this incident)
Those like Sasaki, who are already inside the
barrier are given one chance to leave. (So this
explains the confusion over how they were going
to be notified of the current situation with
a barrier.) He says, that If she so chooses
to leave, she’ll awaken outside the barrier.
Confused with his wording of everything,
Sasaki questions if she's still dreaming,
but Kenjaku replies that the space between dreams
and reality is a curse… (WHICH IS MASSIVE, LIKE
IS THE DREAM SPACE EVEN POSSIBLY EVEN A DOMAIN OF
SOME KIND THAT PEOPLE CAN MANIPULATE THEMSELVES?)
Like idk if this dude was the only
one to show up PERSONALLY TO SASAKI,
BUT he takes ahold of her hand and warns her
to be careful. Then as he slowly guides her
to the safety of the barrier exit, we get
to witness the current carnage taking place
across the battlefield. Then skipping back to
the duo just before they part ways for good,
Kenjaku mysteriously thanks Sasaki
for getting along with his son.
Instantly after she wakes up outside the barrier
with the other OG friend from chapter or Episode
one, Iguchi, who's glad to have found someone
he knows. He points out the gigantic barrier
wall and explains that everyone saw the
same man during their dream. HOWEVER,
to further go into my point on him
physically meeting her unlike the others,
Sasaki asks if the man mentioned
his son, but that isn't the case.
Skipping back now to the present-day, which
is now the 11th of November, Yuji and Megumi
continue planning for the game. They're unable to
find a player named the "Angel" but apparently,
they'll know them when they see them. Big
Hakari decides that him and his boy Panda
will go to the Tokyo No. 2 Colony while
Yuji and Megumi head into the No. 1 and
Kirara stays outside the barrier. (BTW
ITS RECENTLY COME TO MY ATTENTION THAT
APPARENTLY KIRARA IS NEITHER A MALE OR A FEMALE
SO APOLOGIES FOR NOT REALIZING IN THE LAST VIDEO,
BUTT, IT DOES GO TO SHOW HOW GEGE IS. DUDE
JUST KNOWS WHATS GOING ON) ANYWAYS ANWAYS
Hakari plans to handle this
mysterious Hajime Kashimo
himself since they're the player with the
most points and is likely the strongest...
Yuji begins to bring up that perhaps he and
Megumi shouldn't travel together due to how
Sukuna has been acting hella sus with him.
However, Megumi just tells Yuji to shut up
and to stop being so self centered because
the others can't exactly change their roles…
After a lil squabble between the boys, it skips
forth to 12:00 P.M the next day when everyone all
reaches their designated barriers inside Tokyo.
Before entering Kogane explains that inside the
barriers the lethal competition known as the
Culling game is taking place and ask if the
new players are willing to enter and declare
their participation in the game. At probably
the exact same time, Megumi, Yuji, Panda and
Hakari don't hesitate and all agree to enter.
Diving into Tokyo Colony No.1, we find this
babe, Hanyu asking for a signal from a dude
she's forcing to work for her called Rin.
He tells her that he can't do anything if
no one shows up which leaves Hanyu annoyed.
She activates her cursed technique, shaping
her hair into the rear of a dope ass looking jet,
then threatens to run Rin over if he mouths off.
Outside and approaching the colony, Megumi
explains to the absolutely confused Yuji that
they need to be wary of incarnated sorcerers
that’ve lived throughout the past eras. Still
somehow confused over this, Megumi says that
some of the players are from a thousand years
ago and even those from only a 100 or 200 years
ago have a completely different mindset compared
to the modern-day. First and foremost they are
sorcerers who valued life differently and fighting
to the death was a normal thing for them. Some
people even desire to achieve an honorable end
in battle and thats why Megumi thinks they agreed
to become players, to achieve the warrior like
death they couldn't before. Megumi doesn't believe
they'll be able to negotiate with past sorcerers
to which Yuji adds on that they need to be wary
of not just people but cursed spirits as well.
They knock on the barrier wall to the Tokyo
No. 1 Colony and immediately Kogane appears
to greet them. It announces that the Culling
Game is taking place inside and anyone who
enters will become a player in the deadly
competition. Megumi declares his participation,
but oddly like maybe you guys all say, but
megumi doesn't pick on it here, Kogane never
asks Yuji ever if he wants to join.. Interesting
fr anyways! Determined to save his sister,
Megumi reminds Yuji that their first move
is to get information on Hiromi Higuruma.
The duo steps inside the barrier,
HOWEVER they're suddenly separated,
sent randomly to different locations inside of the
colony. Yuji finds himself falling from the sky,
confused by his circumstances while also wondering
where Megumi is. Its then explained to us that
when a player enters the game's barrier, they're
transferred to one of nine locations. Certain
individuals position themselves at those locations
to literally spawn camp unsuspecting people who
don't know this unspoken rule. Skipping back over
to the simp who’s actually one of these spawn
campers, he notices Yuji falling from the sky
and uses a guiding light baton to signal Hanyu.
Using her cursed technique to propel
herself, HANYU BURSTS THROUGH THE AIR
RAMMING DIRECTLY INTO THE CHEST OF YUJI. She
carries on and smashes him straight through
two buildings with an attack that would've
utterly pulverized most players. However,
Yuji is just freaking build different, like
man is constructed of a different material,
somehow he quickly recovers from the impact,
surprising Hanyu. Sliding back across the roof
of a building, Yuji manages to get some
footing and takes his fighting stance.
Recognizes her opponent's toughness Hanyu calls
her partner to her side, but Yuji quickly throws
a rock he picked up in the previous attack that
hits Hanyu in her stomach, seriously injuring her.
Heavily injured, she slowly beings losing altitude
before falling into the building below her.
Behind a surprised Yuji, Hanyu's partner, who’s
this bulky ass dude called Haba appears using
his helicopter-like cursed technique to
levitate. He angrily, he demands to know
what Yuji has done to his woman. Over on
a nearby building Rin notices that Haba
has appeared and that Hanyu was easily taken
down. Thinking on this newcomer for a second,
Rin thinks he might know him before
remembering he's someone named Itadori.
Meanwhile, Megumi who I tell you aint no SIMP,
knocks down a female player and draws his
cursed tool. She asks him why he’d do that,
but Megumi angrily replies that its
because she literally attacked him.
He asks this hella cute girl like oml,
that hair style is to FREAKING FIRE.
LIKE CHILL GEGE.. ANYYWAYS he asks for info
on Higuruma but she instantly starts acting
difficult. She says that she'll only give
him the information if he acts as her knight
and protects her. (Which is like damn
girl, you would have fit in perfectly if
you got spawn in fire force with Arthur
hahaha) Reluctantly our knight agrees,
but not in the way she wants which annoys
her. He tells her to walk in front and
only promises to protect her if she's
telling the truth… If this isn't the case,
he implies that he’ll literally go demon time
on her ass and get some points. Unlike Yuji,
Megumi literally doesn't care at all about racking
up one hundred points on his own if need be.
Unintimidated, the girl responds with a devious
smirk and tells Megumi to instead call her Remi.
Back in the battle with Yuji, he begins his
fight with Haba by tossing a stone charged
with cursed energy directly at him. This
doesn't pose much of a threat though as,
he easily destroys it with his fast-rotating
propeller. Seeing this, Yuji uses the opening
to close the distance, he runs across the
roof of the building and uses his cracked
physical strength to leap high into the air
grabbing his enemies leg. He then flings his
ass directly down and drags him through the
side of a building utterly destroying it.
Haba manages to get loose and tries
counterattacking, but Yuji see’s it
in time and decides to retreat. He realizes
that Haba isn't taking advantage of the high
ground and only attacks with the weapon on
his head. (BTW I just noticed, BUT both of
the people Yuji has fought here so far have some
weird ass obsession with turning their heads into
some sort of military vehicle, like Hanyu’s got
her Jet and obviously this dude ‘s got a fetish
for helicopters… Anyways Yuji leads this dude
indoors where its much more confined. HOWEVER,
Haba instantly drops down after Yuji, confident
that this propellers can literally shred
everything in sight. Finding him, Haba spins
toward his opponent headfirst like a drill,
attempting to obliterate everything in his path.
Thinking, Yuji believes that Hanyu was easily
defeated because her hair-based technique left
the rest of her body unguarded by cursed energy,
but no matter how tough it is, the head will
always remain a vital spot, So as long as he can
hit him without touching the propellers Yuji is
confident he’ll be able to destroy his opponent.
As his adversary finally closes in, Yuji goes
pure demon mode and punches Haba directly in
the top of his head, instantly stopping him
in his tracks and leaving the bulked up dude
bleeding from the head. Still Despite his brain
getting pinged around inside of his own skull,
Haba remains standing. He begins laughing and
overconfidently assumes Yuji broke his hand.
Then just as he says Yuji is finished, our
boy doesn't even care and casually finishes
Haba off with a kick sending him flying back
through the corridor. Standing there shaking
off the damage, Yuji realizes he still
needs to ask this man about Higuruma.
Yet as as the confused Yuji goes to ask
him, Rin suddenly appears behind him,
saying that he knows about Higuruma and asks if
Yuji actually remembers him. (Rin btw is just
another random dude from Yuji’s old highschool
that Kenjaku has done the dirty with. He wasn't
friends with Yuji and Yuji funnily enough
doesn't even recall who he is. Rin notices
that Yuji is obviously suspicious of him,
so he says he really only knows him as the
Tiger of West Junior High, which embarrasses
Yuji. (Good old episode one reference there)
Meanwhile, back with Megumi as he walks through
the streets with Remi, he asks her if she's not
a sorcerer from the past. She confirms she's from
the modern-day, prompting Megumi to question her
reason for fighting. To which she explains that
players who began inside the colony have been
experiencing the Culling Game for twelve days
already. She's not participating in the game
to win, most people like her are just trying to
survive. Remi claims she's seen players go mad
with power and tells Megumi to stop thinking
in terms of time periods as its pointless now.
Hearing this, Megumi realizes that he accidentally
mislead Yuji with their plans earlier.
Due to this Megumi tells Remi to wait up and
reveal where she's leading him. Instantly raging
at him, Remi refuses because Megumi could simply
eliminate her after he gets this information,
but he argues that he could lose
Higuruma's location if Remi dies.
At the same time, Yuji asks Rin why
he's helping since he was just with
the previous sorcerers but Rin reveals he was
being forced to work for them and would've been
eliminated soon anyway. Hearing this Yuji
finally stops and asks where Higuruma is.
Then in some pure cheekiness its revealed through
Rin and Remi that Higuruma's location is in one
of two different area’s. So obviously
one is lying, Rin claims Higuruma is in
Ikebukuro while Remi says he's in Shinjuku.
Having both gained this info separately,
Yuji and Megumi hope that the other is
headed to their destination. Yet as we know,
one of them is indeed being misled
and instead its shown that someone
is actually taking them to another mysterious
but absolutely RIPPED man hoarding receipts.
Going into a flashback now where we find, Rin and
another student who were approached by bullies.
BIG BRAIN RIN using his 1000IQ didn't stand up
to the aggressors, but he knew how to act so the
bullies wouldn't get agitated and would instead
stop bothering him. He knew the bullies were
arrogant despite not being smart or athletic
so he focused on staying out of their way. He
always smiled and went with the flow even at other
people's expense because nobody would bother him.
However, in that same instance, our young
legend refused to sit by and watch someone
else get bullied. Rin just assumed
another moron showed up who wouldn't
know how to avoid trouble, but it turned
out to be the Tiger of West Junior High,
BIG FREAKING YUJI ITADORI. The bullies
attempted to beat up on the newcomer,
but all three are utterly fodderised and brutally
knocked out by just a single hit each. Turning to
Rin, he asks if he’s next, but Rin was too
shocked and could only stutter in response.
Skipping back to reality and over with the two
lovebirds as they get off at Kahamecho Station,
Megumi immediately expresses some concerns
about going through Ikebukuro. He believes
they should've taken a more direct route to
Shinjuku instead, but Remi argues that the
route is simple for her and she has a base
nearby where she wants to rest and bathe at.
Meanwhile, Rin takes Yuji to a theater in
Ikebukuro that Higuruma uses as his base. Excited
to have quickly located his target, Yuji thanks
Rin. Concerned tho, Rin asks if Yuji is really
going inside alone, to which he says that he's in
a hurry to meet up with an ally and assures Rin
he'll be able to escape if anything goes wrong.
Yuji like the happy moron he is skips off into
the theater without a care in the world, while
Rin laments sitting idly by unable to stop him.
After entering the theater and rolling down some
stairs, someone else introduces himself as Reggie,
but as per usual with GEGE and him skipping around
throughout this section, he's not greeting Yuji,
NO, infact Megumi has walked into an ambush in
Remi's "base" where another player was waiting
for him. Reggie reveals to Megumi that Remi
tricked him which immediately sends Megumi
into a rage. Pissed off, he looks back at
Remi who simply tries to taunt him now that
she's supposedly safe. Not worried at all
tho, our female loving Megumi, tells her to
shut up then instantly summons his Divine Dog:
Totality, stating that they're wasting his time.
Remember how Yuji was just suprised before this,
WELL Yuji upon entering the theater finds Higuruma
chilling in a bathtub filled with water while
he's still fully clothed in his suit.. (Man I
love Higuruma, dude gets the coolest introductions
and honestly looks so clean here. Im not to sure
what film aswell, but I know for a fact this
whole clothed and chilling in the bathtub is
from a movie that ive seen but I just cant
remember it right now. Someone PLEEASE leme
know what its from down in the comments below
<3) Anyways anyways, laying there in that Belle
Delphine holy bath water Higuruma claims it
feels better than he expected, which is LIKE
HOLY DUDE CHILL NAh JK ahaha. Higuruma explains
that he’s going off the rails and doesn't care
about anything anymore, so he's trying stuff
he never thought he would've done in the past.
Hearing him ramble, Yuji finds it kinda
funny but since he’s the protag he tries
to get straight to the point and asks the suited
man to talk, but the lawyer claims it costs five
thousand yen every half hour. Higuruma refutes
this as just a joke because he wanted to play the
part of the greedy lawyer for once. Yuji who’s
obviously like yo wtfug is this dude on quickly
realizes he's not an incarnated sorcerer from the
past. Due to our GENIUS Itadori deducing this,
he believes that they can communicate and
make a deal instead of fighting. (but ya know,
if we go off what Remi was saying then right
now Yuji is utterly stuffed either way and wont
be able to talk.) Anyways Yuji reveals his and
megumi’s points plan, but hearing it Higuruma
declines because he believes the Culling Game
presents a few possibilities he's interested in.
So obviously, our ex lawyer has kinda gone a
bit nuts with his sudden powers and wants to
know more about the rules of the Culling Game in
comparison to Societies. Higuruma presents the
question of what if the Culling Game punished
rule-breakers without charges, prosecutions,
or trials. (We FULLY IN THAT LAW AND ORDER ARC
RN, MAN IS THE PROTAGINIST OF HIS OWN LIFE.)
Japans rouge lawyer recognizes that the rules of
the game aren't perfect, but he still wants to
preserve the basic mechanics of the game and see
the cursed technique removal process for himself.
Yuji who’s probably like omg dude chill,
trys to get Higuruma to understand that
the Culling Game is a ritual for
sacrificing everyone in Japan,
but he doesn't believe it. Instead he points out
the Culling Game's rules celebrate permanence,
something Yuji can't argue with because
he literally doesn't even understand it
himself. Running out of options and patience,
Yuji like the muscle-head he is opts for his
own form of persuasion. Getting ready to
throw some freaking hands he demands he let
him use his points. However, soaking wet
just like myself after reading this arc,
Higuruma stands up out of the tub and asks Yuji if
he's ever killed someone. Then armed with a gavel
in hand and his shikigami by his side, Higuruma
claims that it feels better than expected.
Standing opposite him, Yuji knows Higuruma has
eliminated at least twenty players, Because of
this, Yuji decides to stay on the defensive to
anticipate an attack. Unexpectedly though Yuji is
caught off guard as Higuruma instantly activates
his Domain Expansion: Deadly Sentencing. Noting
the immediate danger, Yuji rushes the lawyer and
tries to attack him before the curses technique
can activate. Yuji throws a head kick but his
foot slows and stops right before it can reach
his opponent. Higuruma explains that his domain
forbids the use of physical violence on each
other, which causes Yuji to be transported
back to the other end of his courtroom.
Judgeman which is the name of the Shikigami,
begins stating that Yuji is under suspicion
of entering the a Pachinko Parlor on July 16,
2017, in Sendai City, despite being underage.
Yuji isn't sure what's happening at first
until he remembers the parlor Judgeman is
referring to. As per usual Yuji literally cant
lie and makes it pretty obvious he's been there.
Higuruma explains that Judgeman knows everything
about everyone in the domain. Its explained that
Higuruma isn't privy to all of this information
beforehand and the verdict is solely decided
by the arguments presented in the courtroom.
Additionally, as a confused Yuji reacts to this,
some evidence in a folder randomly appears that's
been submitted by Judgeman to be looked over. It's
not necessarily conclusive but our boy who
physically cannot lie, won't be informed of
what's inside either. Instead his goal is to
defend his case and dispel all doubt to win an
innocent verdict from Judgeman... (So yes, WELL ya
thought the perfect preparation arc was crazy with
some of the techniques like Remi’s and how they
worked, BUT I can tell you for a FACT father GEGE
was just warming up his holy pencil. Like my brain
when writing these scripts sometimes and figuring
out how the techniques exactly work is mental,
everything just feels so well thought out.)
Anywayyys Anyways this trial-based cursed
technique makes Yuji realize he's being
prosecuted by an actual lawyer... The absence
of a fatal attack in Higuruma's domain makes
Yuji a past convo with the thumb where he
explained that a Domain Expansion was a more
common technique for sorcerers of the past
because they didn't incorporate guaranteed
hits. (Which is different to todays, as
I think so far throughout the series,
everyone who’s cast a domain has had a sure
hit guarantee). Old-school domains used to be
used in a way to force people to obey the specific
conditions of their cursed technique. Constructing
a domain with a can't-miss attack, like Dagon's
or Jogo's for example requires a lot of skill
and the number of users with them heavily
decrease over time. Which is why most people
have to bet on surviving the sure-hit domain
to defeat their enemy where-as Yuji surmises
that Higuruma's domain is the old-school type,
meaning it isn't necessarily lethal and it cant
physically harm Yuji if he sticks with the
conditions that Higuruma explained beforehand.
Continuing to explain, Higuruma says that
both participants each have one chance to
make a statement. Once both parties have made
their case against each other, Judgeman will
deliver a verdict. Yuji asks what happens
if he's found guilty but Higuruma isn't sure
how to answer that question. Instead, he tells
Yuji he has one of three options as a response:
silence, confession or denial. Surprised,
Yuji asks if it's fine that he lies in court,
to which Higuruma points out that there would
be no need for trials if everyone was honest,
then tells Yuji to hurry his slow ass up and make
his statement because Judgeman is impatient...
Taking a moment, Yuji thinks about how to
properly defend himself. He knows he did
go into the pachinko parlor that day and even won
on the machines. (cause man is always winning fr,
Yuji on top baby) This means that lying is
his way to get off clean but he isn't sure
what the evidence is. After going over all
of the hypotheticals, Yuji decides to go
with the second option which was confession and
claims he only went inside to use the bathroom.
However, Higuruma is apart of the damn
Yu-Gi-Oh universe and had set his trap.
Instantly he reveals it retorting with the
evidence, which turns out to be a damn photo
of Yuji inside using a cash exchange. Absolutely
dumbfounded with his own stupidity Yuji facepalms,
while Seto Kaiber himself adds that after gaining
all of this evidence it puts his supposed restroom
story into question, because of this he states
that he’s certain Yuji entered the parlor with
the intent of playing the pachinko machines. Yuji
tryna be cheeky asks what law he's breaking then,
to which its explained that the premises
forbids the entry of minors. Currently in
Japan there aren't any laws for punishing minors
over this, but its still considered illegal.
Puzzled he states this is an unfair trial
because there's nothing he could've said
to win. However, Higuruma reveals that
Japan only forbids minors to gamble,
meaning cash exchanges are separate
entities in themselves, because of this,
if Yuji wanted to win the verdict all he
actually needed to say was that he’d never
seen the Pachinko Parlor before. Having come
to a conclusion Judgeman finds Yuji guilty,
sentencing him to "confiscation". (FINALLY WE
CAN GET INTO THE PROPER BEATDOWN MATERIAL AND,
YALL DONT REALIZE THIS BUT AFTER THIS FIGHT
HERE. WE DONT SEE YUJI FOR A VERRRY LONG TIME.
SO SAAAVOUR THIS FIGHT BEFORE WE MOVE ONTO
SOME OF THE COOLEST NEW CHARACTERS IN ANMIE!)
Anywaysss So randomly the domain is
dispelled and Judgeman disappears,
as it does so Higuruma immediately attacks by
throwing his gavel which connects with Yuji’s
arm dealing WAY more damaged more than it
should have. Smelling blood in the water,
Higuruma closes the distance and summons his gavel
back to its hand. He then charges it with cursed
energy to increase its size and proceeds
to smash through Yuji's defense, sending
him crashing through several seats in the theater.
Getting back up Yuji realizes that he’s in an even
worse situation that originally thought, now he’s
completely lost the ability to manipulate cursed
energy. BUUT honestly Higuruma got the worst match
up here, as we know for a fact our boys physical
strength is so damn broken it comparable
to having a freaking heavenly restriction.
Continuing to attack, Higuruma lunches and smashes
down his mallet atop Yuji. Seeing it though,
Yuji jumps back to avoid it but this
insanely BIG BRAIN LAWYER makes the
gavel appear in his other hand, allowing
him to quickly attack yet again. After the
barrage ends Yuji who’d narrowly managed to
dodge, tries to counterattack with an elbow,
but Higuruma, instead of switching hands like
he just was, now morphs the shape of the gavel
into a flexible hook which manages to wrap
around Yuji's elbow before tossing him away.
Its actually crazy when you think about how strong
Higuruma actually is, like this dude didnt have a
cursed technique up until extremely recently and
only learned the basics of barrier techniques by
analyzing his own Domain Expansion. Somehow
this mad genius worked backwards from there,
and gained an instinctive grasp of how to
reinforce his body with cursed energy. So
somehow within just twelve days of his awakening,
Higuruma managed to blossom into a fighter whos
comparable to someone like freaking Nanami
or Mei Mei. Even before entering the Colony
so for literally no points, he exorcised a few
cursed spirits and then soon after entering has
eliminated at least twenty players becoming one
of the 2 current frontrunners in terms of points.
Standing there Higuruma asks him if
he can't control his cursed energy,
which confuses him because he thinks Higuruma
is the reason for it, but apparently,
the confiscation penalty takes away the
person's ability to use techniques in the
first place. So since Yuji doesn't possess
a technique of any kind, the effect fell
to literally stopping him from utilizing his
cursed energy altogether. Concerned over this,
Higuruma quickly surmises that it must
be due to an incredible physical prowess.
Determined to crush Yuji with all his might,
Higuruma shifts his gavel into a staff and
attacks with a flurry of swings. Using his insane
agility though, Yuji is able to avoid each swing
then grabs onto the staff's middle section, only
for Higuruma to make it instantly vanish before
he can pull it away. Jumping back, Yuji then kicks
the bathtub directly towards the lawyer, however
he simply destroys it with his gavel, unleashing
a rush of water and broken tub pieces. Erupting
through the water, Higuruma increases his gavel
to a freaking massive size and slams it down on
top of Yuji, HOWEVER, LIKE SOMEONE PLEASE EXPLAIN
TO ME HOW EVEN THIS ISNT ENOUGH TO CRUSH YUJI,
it even Impresses Higuruma who compares his
experience to fighting an indestructible doll.
Yuji who realizes he’s in deep water
though, considers Higuruma's technique
to be exceptionally strong and thinks this must
also mean there's some sort of relative weakness.
He frantically recalls his interactions beforehand
and remembers the mental notes he made about the
trial-based cursed technique. Then in a moment
that blows me away every damn time I read it,
Yuji calls out and demands a retrial (like how
does he know what this even is) anyways because
of this it instantly transports them both inside
the domain to some sort of momentary safety.
Due to what happened in the previous trial,
if Yuji doesn't confess his guilty outright,
he can request a retrial that
can't be refused. Yet this play
of Yuji’s utterly backfires as in
the new trial Judgeman announces
that our boy is being accused of mass
murder in Shibuya on October 31, 2018.
Then like last time, Higuruma receives
some evidence to go over, but before he
even has a chance to speak, Yuji immediately
confesses his guilt. As we all know by now,
he won't, let alone cant lie and
will refuse to deny what happened,
shocking the lawyer. Bleeding from its eyes
with rage, the irate Judgeman declares Yuji
is guilty… He punishes Yuji with confiscation
again as well as an additional punishment which
turns out to none other that the freaking death
penalty. (For those of you who’re wondering.
YES that's the 3rd time now our boy has
been sentenced to death in some manner)
After Judgeman gives Yuji his penalty,
Higuruma’s gavel transforms into an
Executioner's Sword which has the added effect
of being able to kill its target with one cut.
Higuruma believes empathizing with people
means understanding all their weaknesses,
but he can't help but perceive that
fragility itself is ugly. Including Yuji,
everyone is weak and ugly to himself regardless
of their aspirations to improve in life.
While Higuruma continues screaming at him, Yuji
tries to keep him back by launching several
theater chairs in his direction. Then being his
cheeky old self, Yuji also throws his Jujutsu
High jacket to distract Higuruma leaving him a
moment to get in and behind him. Quickly Higuruma
turns but in that moment also notices Yuji who
now throws his hoodie and manages to block the
lawyers sight momentarily. Dropping to the floor,
Yuji throws a sweeping kick but Higuruma who’s
somehow able to keep up is able to just jump
above it. As he floats there Higuruma prepares
to land his final blow with the executions
sword while Yuji below prepares an uppercut.
In usual manga fashion though, we get
absolutely cucked as it quickly goes
into a past conversation between Mr. Yokizawa
and our current mentally insane Lawyer. There
Higuruma refused to become a judge because
he felt like his ambitions in life weren't
good enough. Its explained that he’s reminded
of this memory because Yuji for some bizarre
reason confessed to a crime he did not
commit. The evidence in the retrial was
about Sukuna’s massacre and Higuruma knows that
Yuji wasn't the one who committed that crime,
so he cant seem to understand why Yuji
would confess to something he didn't do.
Because of his confusion over this, Higuruma
willingly deactivates the Executioner's Sword
allowing Yuji's insanely strong uppercut to
land, like this just pure physical strength,
look at how RIPPED HE IS RN Anyways,
this punch directly hits him in the
body probably cracking a rib or 2 and
sending him crashing back into the seats.
Before he even bothers to get up from the hit,
Higuruma states that the absence of reason or
control signifies non-components. He adds that
Sukuna was in possession of the body and since
Yuji didn't surrender control willingly, he is
innocent. Yuji doesn't see it that way and he
still claims responsibility for it, believing
that death really only occurred because he's
too weak. Yuji, who’s still confused
over why he deactivated his technique,
asks him so asks. Getting back up now, Higuruma
explains that he remembered why he got into law
in the first place as there are still other
weak people out there who need help his help.
Higuruma invites Yuji to sit down after
he's gotten his clothes back on and
agree’s to give him his 100 points, however before
he does so he asks the young sorcerer if he's ever
killed anyone on purpose, to which Yuji somberly
responds that he has. Then in a quick flash,
we see the moments proceeding Keita’s trial
and how Higuruma had brutally murdered the
prosecutor and judge. Thinking on this he
asks Yuji if felt awful about it as well…
(So that brings the first beatdown of this
amazing colony to an end, but one thing I do
want to say is god damn I love Higuruma and I
really hope that he sticks around in the story,
even after the culling game, dude would be
a great addition to the Jujutsu Tech staff.
Honestly I think he’s truly a good person who
was blinded just by how shit society is and
this insane increase in power he’d just received
from Kenjaku. Which makes me wonder aswell, are
all these new techniques modern day civilians
have found themselves with actually just another
reincarnation and instead of a person being
reincarnated its the cursed technique itself thats
been placed inside of an individual who meets the
right conditions. Its just an idea BUT anyways
Now that the two are chilling out Higuruma
tells his Kogane to add a rule to the Culling
Game that allows players to transfer points
between one another. As Yuji anxiously waits
Kogane relays the message to the game
master but just moments he breathes a
sigh of relief as the rule is allowed and
Higuruma transfers one of his points to
Yuji so neither of them will be affected by
cursed technique removal for nineteen days.
Abruptly getting up and leaving Higuruma says
goodbye but Yuji who’s just like yo wait up,
asks him what he's going to do now. He explains
to him that he wants to use Higuruma’s strength
to help them in the Culling Game, but the lawyer
explains that he’d killed a few people before
coming to Tokyo. Due to how he feels about it,
he wants take responsibility and plans to turn
himself in once the barrier opens. But until
that time happens, he's going to ponder his best
course of action and doesn't feel comfortable
staying around Yuji because it'll just make him
hate himself more. (Which is probably alluring to
Yuji just having those super solid morals in not
wanting to kill people and literally castrating
himself over all of the crap Sukuna has put people
thru when in charge of his body!) Anyways
anyways! sadly Higuruma leaves the theater,
leaving our boy alone to lament over the
situation despite accomplishing his goal...
(NOOW WE ONTO THE NEXT ROUND OF HEAT BOYS
SECOND MASSIVE BATTLE OF THIS DOPE ARC,
PLUS IDK IF YOUVE SEEN GEGE’s RECENT POSTS TO DO
WITH HXH AND HIM HONORING TOGASHI’s AETHERAL LEVEL
OF WRITING… BUT DUDE SAID HE HOPED HE COULD WARM
THE PAGES TO A SIMILAR DEGREE TO TOGASHI SENSEI’S
WRITING IN YEARS TO COME. I DONT BELIEVE HOW
HUMBLE THIS GOAT IS! LIKE HOW DOESNT REALIZE
HE IS ALREADY SETTING HIS PAGES ON FREAKING FIRE
AND HAS BECOME DEFINATLY BECOME ONE OF IF NOT THE
HOTTEST DUDE ON THE BLOCK WITH A CONSISTENTLY
RELEASING MANGA!) Anywayyys Anyways now!
Meanwhile over the other side of the Tokyo
Colony, Reggie commends Megumi as he says he
can already tell the young man is strong just
based on his shikigami. Unbeknownst to Remi,
Reggie was actually just using her to lure in
potential allies and now seeing Megumi here
he asks him to join their group, then asks him
what he knows about the culling game. Without
mentioning Master Thumb, Megumi reveals that
it is a ritual for bringing Japanese people
to the other side so that they're considered
no longer human. Hearing this explanation,
Reggie cracks up and asks if Megumi knows
Kenjaku surprising the younger sorcerer as
he figured he'd run into a sorcerer with
a connection to Kenjaku sooner or later.
Reggie explains that the ritual explanation
is probably just a cover for Kenjaku's real
plan (ANNNND HOOOOOOOLLY I DONT WANNA SPOIL
ANYTHING I WANNA CATCH UP AND REVEAL THE TRUE
PLAN MYSELF BECAUSE REGGIE MAY LOOK LIKE A SILLY
MOFO, BUT THIS DUDE IS A GENIUS FOR STATING THIS
CHEECKY FORSHADOWING HERE FOR US). Anyways
continuing with his big brain explanation,
assuming one thousand players were equally divided
among ten colonies, Reggie suggests that each
colony of a hundred players is top-heavy in regard
to the players skill level. Players like Kashimo
and Higuruma are much stronger than most of the
other combatants and between the two of them,
they have already eliminated roughly sixty
other players within just the first twelve days.
Which makes sense to Megumi as the Tokyo No. 1
Colony has been extremely quiet ever since he
entered. He asks Reggie if the strong have
already weeded out all the weak this early
on and if the game has reached a deadlock because
due to those circumstances. Reggie confirms this,
then goes on to explain that the transferal
process isn't just a way to spread out players,
but actually a way to stimulate a
second awakening of new modern-day
peoples cursed techniques. Some of
the weaker people even die during
that transfer but this doesn't benefit the
ritual the same way a drawn-out melee would.
Reggie then drops a freaking bomb saying that
Kenjaku is currently overseas in China meeting
with government officials there. (So its
like YO what’s going on with Mr. Xi and
his boys in xina) Anyways he explains that he
is pretty certain that Kenjaku will drop his
own metaphorical bomb on all the players once
only the strongest ones remain. At that point,
Reggie believes the Culling Game
will have served its purpose,
so for now he’s just focused on gathering
strong allies and storing points.
Megumi asks how Remi fits into this plan because
she is a weakling with no value. Reggie clarifies
that Remi is useful for luring in people as they
tend to drop their guard around a woman. Megumi
asks Reggie if the total points of everyone in his
group add up to 100, to which Reggie confirms that
they have over a hundred points total. Having been
confirmed on his suspicions, Megumi reveals that
a new rule will be soon added that allows players
to give each other points. He demands that Reggie
and his allies hand over all their points
and only then will he consider joining them.
Immediately Reggie is like oh well I guess this
talk has broken down, causing a random fodder
player too shoot out behind Megumi and tries
to attack him with his set of claw hands. (So
obviously this dude is another of the guys I like
to call the body modification curse users, with
Yuji we had the cap dude and ofcourse the rocket
hair girl, then now with Megumi we’ve got claw
dude! Anyways Megumi manages to slip into Hari's
shadow. Then as his Divine Dog: attacks Reggie,
Megumi reappears from below the fodder claw man,
picking him up and simply throwing his ass off the
side of the building. As per usual though, Megumi
always double taps his opponents and commands
Nue to divebomb him, shocking the player and
slamming him into the ground below, merking him.
Back in the building, two kitchen knives are
suddenly shoved into the Divine Dog's mouth,
incapacitating the shikigami. As Megumi turns
back, Reggie says that he knows what he’s upto
and warns his adversary that he'll die
if he doesn't fight for real. On cue,
a random eye suddenly appears over the
side of the building next to Megumi and
abruptly detonates causing an explosion
which almost even takes out Reggie.
Above them we find a player named Iori Hazenoki,
one of Reggie's allies and another of those body
modification curse users. The now one-eyed
sorcerer begins breaking off some of his
teeth while asking if their target is dead,
However Megumi is seen quickly darting out
of the smoke and immediately avoiding a
follow up attack sent by Remi. He manages
to grab her hair and slams her onto the ground.
Aggressively he asks her if she's had enough,
but before she can answer Hazenoki jumps down
from the floor above and tosses his teeth at
Megumi. At the same time, Reggie also sends
thru a few receipts that transform into gas
and splash all over Megumi soaking him. Then in
some crazy ass combination with the gasoline,
Hazenoki's detonates his teeth resulting
in a massive blast that erupts through
the top of the building, seemingly
taking out both Remi and Megumi.
Exciting a room, Reggie asks if they're finished
but Hazenoki says he saw Megumi duck into another
room to avoid taking damage too. Inside of that
said room, Megumi moves a door that he used to
protect himself and asks if Remi understands,
as the explosions could've easily killed her,
proving that she’s completely disposable.
Megumi tries to leave her behind but Remi
attempts stabs him again with her hair, then
instantly switching up she desperately begs
Megumi to say that he likes her and that he
will protect her. Disgusted, Megumi realizes
that Remi is the type of trash who only cares
about words rather than someone's actions.
Chizuru, remember that random dude Megumi
disposed of at the start of the scuffle,
WELL turns out he didnt actually die and
stupidly the man decides to rejoins the
battle. He compliments Megumi for getting
the better of him before but notes that
the student must be in rough shape now. He
mentions it was a pain scaling the building
and hearing this Megumi is like what are
you dumb? why didnt ya take the stairs.
Suddenly, both of their Kogane’s appear and
announce that a new rule has been added to
the Culling Game. (So this is obviously the point
in the arc that Yuji and Higuruma’s battle ends,
with him finally adding that new rule). Surprised
and reinvigorated, Megumi smiles. INSTANTLY he
restarts the fight, kicking the fodder fool
back and summoning his prolific Max Elephant,
which materializes inside of the building
completely destroying the upper floors as it
comes thundering down. Sticking with lightning
itself, Megumi then uses Nue to catch himself
allowing him to mount Chizuru in mid-air.
After getting on top and still falling down,
Megumi smashes his face over and over
with the hilt of his sword. Having crashed
heavily into the ground below him Chizuru,
curses Megumi. YET Before he can get up,
MEGUMI who aint not damn Yuji simply slashes
his face open with his sword and eliminates him.
For a moment, Megumi questions what he's
doing because they'll need more points in
the future but quickly refocuses by
reminding himself that Tsumiki won't
have to participate in the killing now.
As Kogane rewards him with five points,
Megumi reaffirms to himself that he just needs
to deal with the difficulties as they come.
Descending down to ground level where their
opponent is, Reggie is left surprised and
even embarrassed by Chizuru’s lack of skill,
having not actually been able to display his
cursed technique. Megumi notices that he's
still outnumbered 2 to 1 and is now feeling
the effects of the first explosion.
Thinking on what to do for a moment,
he deduces that he can't flee or use his Domain
Expansion because the environment still isn't
compatible with his technique. Before he can
think up anything, Hazenoki abruptly spits out
another one of his bomb teeth, but completely and
utterly out of nowhere someone literally no one
saw coming showed up and took the blast face
first like an actual champion to protect him.
As all of them stand there confused the newcomer
named Fumihiko Takaba. (who was the failing
comedian that I introduced right at the end of the
previous JJK video) Well He in one of them like
super hero level voices states, that two-on-one
fights are unfair and calls Reggie and his minion
complete cowards. He adds that their attacks
have done zero damage HOWEVER its shown that the
attack completely busted open his face and head
making it clear he was in fact hurt, confusing
Megumi. Like look at his face the dudes mind is
just like yo wtfug is going on hahah WHO ARE YOU!
Fumihiko Takaba decides to help Megumi
because the thirty-five-year-old can tell
whether someone is good or bad by their
face. Yet after looking at him realizes
Megumi has a bad face but writes it off
as all "revisionist". Megumi is just left
stunned with this random new person,
but regardless of his personality,
this random saved him, so the Jujutsu High
student is willing to trust him for now.
Reggie and Hazenoki don't recognize Takaba,
try asking what time period he's from. Takaba
though who isn't even listening to them explains
that his costume is based on a funny superhero,
causing his intimidation factor to
suddenly flare up while preparing to
tell another absolutely TERRIBLE joke. The
enemy duo prepare for an attack but Takaba
just darts into a JoJo esc pose and tells
a joke that gets a dead silent reaction.
Takaba screams that damn its a tough crowd but
continues to hype himself up nonetheless. Even
though his opponents are stiff, Takaba
will continue to do what he does because
he's an entertainer of the highest degree.
He screams flying forward and delivering a
insane fierce double footed flying dropkick that
connects with Hazenoki’s face sending him crashing
into a building. Standing right there, Reggie
notes that the shift in Takaba's output of cursed
energy and quickly realizes that the failing
comedian is actually strong. Takaba stunting
on em all does a handstand while explaining that
he's an old-school performer who's pro-violence.
Using the confusion to his advantage, Megumi
tries to launch a surprise attack on Reggie
from his own shadow but his foe manages to jump
away from the ground in time to avoid it. Now
back with his new teammate, Megumi trys to
explain Hazenoki's exploding body parts,
but only ends up annoyed telling Takaba
to stop getting so close to his face.
Bringing out Kogane, they use him to confirm
that Higuruma was the one who added the new
rule. He’s surprised and assured to see that
Yuji completed their mission, because of this
he states he's done with this colony and tells
Reggie he'll let him go if he backs off. Reggie
just straight up annoyed now refuses because he
needs to make up for his teammates lost points.
Hazonki recovers from the dropkick he suffered
and calls out to Takaba. The comedian just ignores
him though and instead introduces himself properly
to Megumi. Since Takaba is most likely gonna end
up killing the bomb guy, Megumi requests that
he take Hazenoki's points if possible to which
he accepts on the condition that he continues to
entertain as first and foremost he is a performer.
Satisfied, Takaba begins "sparking" almost
exposing himself to the young man while Hazenoki
in return sends an explosive eye directly at
him. Not fazed, Takaba simply knocks it away
with a random paper fan, then manages to close
the distance on his opponent, sliding in behind
him and utterly destroying his rectum with
pervey sages infamous 1000 years of pain,
sending his enemy into a sever bout of pain.
Enraged and getting fodderised Hazenoki swings
at him but Takaba immediately follows up with a
powerful kick to his dome that sends his opponent
through another building. Standing there megumi
is just left flabbergasted with Takaba’s show
of strength and expresses that he's glad he isn't
his enemy to which Takaba tells him to stay alive
while going off to pound his opponent some more.
Over with Reggie, he stands there thinks Takaba
is toast either way because Hazenoki will go all
out after being mocked so much. With his objective
completed, Megumi tells his adversary to worry
about himself so that he can fight him for real.
Instantly he summons his Max Elephant,
leaving Reggie blown away that Megumi has
such a large Shikigami. Max Elephant attempts
to spray Reggie with a torrent of water but
he somehow manages to quickly dart away from
the burst. Attempting to take him by surprise,
Megumi leaps from a building above but
Reggie notices in time and throws a receipt
which transforms it into a net that ensnares
the falling rabbits. Megumi himself though
narrowly avoids the net and jumps onto
a chain linked fence to break his fall.
As Megumi jumps back into the road, Reggie
activates his innate cursed technique,
Contractual Re-Creation, and
transforms several receipts into
kitchen knives. (So pretty much just like its
shown with him, this contractual recreation
allows him to recreate anything that he has on
these receipts through a contract that he’s made)
anyways! Those said knives fly toward Megumi as
projectiles but he's able to deflect them with a
blade of his own. Some rabbits are pierced by
the knives, allowing Reggie to surmise that,
unlike the other shikigami, they can reappear
regardless of how many are destroyed.
Reggie figures that Megumi has likely figured
out how his cursed technique works, due to this
he uses a receipt to re-create the contract
and endows himself with a relaxing two night
stay at a five-star Japanese inn. In contrast,
Megumi is worn down from the constant fighting
on top of also having used several shikigami
lowering his overall capacity. Reggie surmises
that Megumi can't re-conjure his shikigami after
their injured, and without the flexibility the
divine dog provides him he's limited in his
options. The old schooler adds that both of
them lack big finishing moves and will need to
peck away at each other over time to achieve
victory. To which megumi is like, yeah nah bro in
that case im absolutely fugged so ima run for now.
Out of nowhere Nue swoops down grabbing
Megumi, however Reggie quickly summons
the trash taste boys drones equipped with
the lost luggage cameras to follow his
opponent through the sky while he watches on
a phone. Then summoning a moped, Reggie begins
to pursue his adversary through the streets
and tracks Megumi's position to a gymnasium.
Reggie questions whether he really tried escaping
or if he's infact trying to lure the fight inside.
Inside the gym, Megumi is glad to see the
area is as spacious, looking up he see’s
Reggie appear on the balcony who asks what his
opponent is plotting. Megumi replies that big
Reggie is likely planning something as well and
the latter claims that it's hard to tell because
sorcerers are nothing but con artists. (which is
completely true and I love the idea around it,
its all about conning your enemy into
believing you've played your final move,
BUT actually you’ve just laid a trap and
conned him into a false sense of security)
Anyways LET THE MAIN PART OF THIS ABSOLUTELY
INSANE BATTLE BEGIN!! Suddenly, two truck-kun's
appear out of nowhere and come crashing through
the walls of the building. Acting quickly Megumi
is just able to slip under the vehicles safely,
yet as he watches them crash into the other wall,
two potted plants are re-created above Megumi
that drop down onto his head, cracking his scull
open. Reggie follows up by repeatedly slicing
up Megumi's back and left arm with a small
knife. Having been slashed multiple times, Megumi
tries to retreat, but gets distracted by the
unorthodox projectile Reggie had just re-created,
he’s taken off guard when the silly old carrot
breaks apart and reveals a hidden kitchen
knife inside. Shoooting forth, the knife stabs
straight into Megumi's elbow while Reggie then
follows up with a brutal front kick to the face.
Having been knocked down, Megumi slides across the
gym floor thoroughly overpowered. Its explained
that the things he re-creates behave like
shikigami, obviously knives and such can't
normally fly through the air but Reggie is able
to get them do to so with a single command.
Big FREAKING Megumi though, a man made of
a much darker material responds by stating
that barrier techniques are difficult for him
and he’s simply unable to make an artificial
environment over a real one, However, Megumi
doesn't need to physically create a barrier…
NO instead he can use the entire gymnasium as
a perfect space for his domain. As planned,
Megumi casts his GOD DAMN Domain Expansion,
the insane Chimera Shadow Garden, and forcibly
encloses the barrier around the gym to trap
Reggie inside, sealing his fate... Reggie who
didn't think Megumi was a sorcerer capable of
using Domain Expansion is taken by surprise.
Immediately thought he activates his special
anti-domain technique called Hollow Wicker
Basket, which if you've seen my video
going over all the JJK barrier types,
you know that this is the original form of
the current simple domain. Reggie believes
he's successfully protected himself from
the domain, until four toads appear from
the liquid shadow below his feet and wrap up
both his legs with their tongues. Confused,
Reggie doesn't understand how he's been
hit after using Hollow Wicker Basket. Its
explained that technically Reggie's technique does
nullifies the said guaranteed hit from a domain,
BUT because big old megumi’s domain isn't
complete and doesn't actually have a cant
miss attack it only serves as an extension to
his cursed energy and ten shadows technique..
That imperfection has taken Reggie off guard
and Megumi notices his expression change. Before
Reggie can finish berating Megumi for getting
cocky, he's ambushed by two shadow clones. Reggie
is unable to avoid the barrage of hits due to
the toad's tongues preventing his movements.
After getting pummeled, Reggie falls back and
summons combat knives to sever the toads' tongues.
Free to move again, Reggie summons a machete
and prepares to counterattack. However,
Megumi's clone prevents Reggie from gaining
any momentum by coming up from below to grab
his leg. Then the clone throws Reggie
toward Megumi's main body, who's also
armed with his sword and already bringing it
down on him. Reggie is somehow able to block,
like his reflexes are actually insane, but
now the Uno reverse cards been played by our
boy and its a 3 on 1 with the other shadow clone
appearing and elbowing him directly in the dome.
Heavily damaged now, Reggie just narrowly defends
a slash from Megumi and commends the sorcerer for
the increased function of his cursed technique,
considering it worse than a lethal domain.
Reggie is aware that if Megumi uses Max Elephant
and showers him with water, he'll lose the fight.
Refusing to allow that to happen, he activates
his cursed technique and releases a multitude
of receipts in to the air above his head. Megumi
tries to destroy the receipts using Nue but it's
just not quick enough to stop Reggie’s
Contractual Re-Creation from activating.
Three cars are generated from the
receipts which drop straight into the
shadowy floor. Reggie understands that
the entire domain is Megumi's shadow,
but noticed that Megumi has only kept one
cursed tool on him for the length of the
fight. He theorizes this is because Megumi has
to bear the weight of anything kept within his
shadow and now Reggie is using the cars to
turn the domain's conditions back on Megumi.
Having been forced to the
ground under the immense weight,
Reggie believes Megumi might be able to
summon shinigami still, so he keeps his
guard up and plans to keep piling on weight
until his opponent is completely crushed.
Megumi though, like we all learnt this thoughout
the first battle against that silly old cursed
womb Megumi dunks on, THAT he is literally insane
the dude doest care about his life anymore,
to the point Now he tells Reggie that he's
forgotten something important. He reminds
him that an incomplete domain is still a domain
and there is shadow all around the both of them.
Megumi who doesn't care, suddenly conjures Max
Elephant from the shadows above Reggie causing
the massive Shinigami to drops directly on top of
him. Having turned their fight into a damn weight
lifting competition Megumi remains confident as he
asks Reggie which of them will be crushed first.
Its explained that, the average human being can
only withstand about five to six units of g-force
before losing consciousness. Megumi weighs sixty
kilograms and is carrying 2.4 tons of weight,
which equates to forty units of g-force.
A fully matured elephant weights three to
six tons and Megumi's domain increases
the precision of his cursed technique,
replicating Max Elephant's weight realistically.
With that intense weight falling atop him,
Reggie fractures his right fibula and
heel bone due to the pressure alone.
Reggie laments over not saving the trucks he
used earlier for more weight at this moment.
He's been soaked with water by Max Elephant,
but there are still receipts he can release,
including the special ace he has up his sleeve.
Reggie wonders if he can enter the shadow to
release his ace and finish off Megumi. He
dismisses this idea because anything caught
in the shadow after its dispelled might
be unable to escape. (Which leaves the
idea of possibly other domains or universes
shikigami and curses live in) Furthermore,
he's unsure of what it's actually like inside
the sticky shadow substance. He decides this
option is too risky and tries to withstand
the elephant's weight while releasing his ace.
Reggie attempts to hold up the
elephant with one arm while taking
out the another receipt. Before he can
fully activate Contractual Re-Creation,
Reggie succumbs to Max Elephant's immense
weight and falls into the shadow below him.
Without any buoyancy or resistance inside
the shadow, Reggie falls and begins to
lose consciousness due to the lack of oxygen.
Laying there above his likely defeated opponent,
Megumi waits until he's sure Reggie is dead before
dispelling the domain and emptying his shadow.
Suddenly and coming back like
a damn king riding one his cars
Reggie fly's back exploding through to
the surface. Rescued from certain demise,
Reggie commends Megumi's strength and
admits he's a strong sorcerer before
immediately stating that he's even stronger.
He activates another Contractual Re-Creation
and summons a small, two-story wooden
house that weighs at least thirty tons.
In the next second, Megumi makes an extremely
drastic move. Despite using his ace,
Reggie abruptly finds himself underwater
being strangled by Megumi from behind. Its
explained that now, Megumi is using
his extreme weight to drown Reggie,
but because of just the immense force that's
being placed on him, he has to deactivate his
cursed technique and unregister the weight
of the objects before he does end up dying.
Coming to, Reggie is able to swim back to the
surface for air and realizes he's inside a pool
on the basement level of the gymnasium. Megumi
fled into his shadow and ended the domain,
making it so the house broke the floor
and forced Reggie to fall into the pool
below. It's unclear how Megumi was
able to move despite the weight,
but Reggie theorizes that he did so
by ejecting himself from the shadow.
Megumi strolls on up to his opponent and
tells Reggie his receipts are too wet to use
now. Normally, splashing the receipts with
water isn't enough to make the print fade,
so that alone isn't enough to stop Reggie
from producing things. However, soaking the
receipts prevents Reggie from fulfilling the
condition that requires burning the receipts.
Reggie also notes though that Megumi
can't summon shikigami anymore,
to which the sorcerer agrees stating
that from now on this is a straight
up physical fight to the death… Reggie
though doesn't actually believe this,
he expects Megumi to summon a shikigami and
plans on countering Megumi as soon as he lets up.
Darting in, Reggie's initial bait attack
gets palmed off, but as he planned he uses
that momentum to send Megumi’s sword arm bouncing
back. Having no defense left, Reggie lets loose
with a multitude of kicks smashing the young
sorcerer over and over again. Megumi admits
Reggie is a tough opponent, made evident by his
ability to withstand Max Elephant's, he's also
a talented martial artist with some really dope
ass techniques, but he just isn't fast enough.
Just before Reggie is able to land a direct
hit on Megumi, a portion of the far left side
of Reggie's face, his ear, and much of his left
shoulder are completely sheered off by someone
he thought he’d dealt with already. Having
suffered a lethal blow at blinding speed,
Reggie looks back to see none other than the
Divine Dog: Totality which is just pissed at him,
like the dog even has two scars in its nose from
the knives. Its explained that Megumi was waiting
until Reggie had completely dismissed the dog and
hearing this Reggie repeats that a sorcerer is
indeed nothing but a con artist as he collapses
to the ground in a pool of his own blood.
Reggie lays bleeding out on the ground
looking up at Megumi and realizes that
the domain and the pool concealed that
Megumi could still strike with his Divine
Dog. Itachi fug I mean ahh Megumi didn't flee
into the gym using Nue, he lured Reggie inside.
Megumi inquires as to what Reggie's
relationship to Master Tengen is.
Its shown that there really isn't much
of a relationship, he only knows that
the hermit is immortal and isn't surprised
to find out he's still alive in this time.
Defeated with dignity, Reggie tells his Kogane to
transfer all 41 of his points to Megumi which our
boy is a lil annoyed about but Reggie tells him
to just consider it a good deed before death. He
adds that he's just a spectator and isn't close
with Kenjaku at all. With his final words said,
Reggie tells his executioner to let fate toy
with him before he also dies like a fool,
moments later, Megumi receives five more
points for the death of Reggie Star.
Damn actually SUCH a fire fight like I love how
much foreshadowing for future events its peppered
throughout the story. Like is that how Megumi
will end up dying? having Sukuna who is fate in
this context toy with him before he kills him like
a fool and again those whore past chapter 200 now
also know Big Reggie was correct when it came to
this just being the beginning of something even
larger. Also believe me when I say this guys.
Jujutsu Kaisen is just heating up, over these
next few videos we are going to be getting the
crème dele crop of Jujutsu Kaisen hands. Anyways!
Back over the other side of the city a massive
explosion is set off on the roof of a building.
Hazenoki, who's still fighting with Takaba wonders
if he's finally hit his target, yet the comedian
appears beside Hazenoki and comically encourages
him to stay focused because his opponent is tough.
Continuously irritated by Takaba's antics,
Hazenoki tries to punch him only for his fist
to slide off the new dudes weird saucy coating..
Hazenoki is frustrated by this fight because he
doesn't understand why Takaba won't take damage
regardless of how many times he gets bombed.
Kogane interrupts the battle to inform Hazenoki
that Reggie has been eliminated. Surprised,
Hazenoki decides to walk away from the fight
entirely. Initially, Takaba is fine with this
telling his opponent to bathe and brush his teeth.
Then sticking with his original plan Takaba starts
to pester Hazenoki for his points, only to be
repeatedly denied. So finally its explained that
Fumihiko cursed technique is called Comedian.
Its actually to broken, so broken infact it
has the possibility to rival even that of Gojo,
like anything he's certain will be funny becomes
reality itself for Takaba, but unfortunately
Takaba is completely unaware of how it even works.
Elsewhere, Remi runs through the streets
in a panic. She's distressed because she's
always been told men are supposed
to be wolves who will tear her up,
but they've always taken care of her. (which
what do you mean by getting torn up love,
in New Zealand that is some craazy ass slang)
Anyways She doesn't know how to go on and
still thinks wolves will continue to help her
until she's cornered by a deadly hound which
turns out to be Megumi’s Divine Dog. However,
before Megumi can make good on his threats,
Tsumiki's voice randomly tells her brother to
stop before he kills someone in cold blood,
causing his Divine Dog to disappear and leaving
Remi surprised that she's being let go. Annoyed
and exhausted, Megumi tells his sister to shut
up before he collapses to the ground unconscious.
Just as this happens, no one other than the Angel
herself, Hana Kurusu, descends upon his body.